after the first pictures of the main
actors in the upcoming Netflix The
Witcher series k-ville has now published
the appearance of an unimportant
creature namely the horse Roch Gerald's
most loyal companion also to be seen on
it is the witcher's armor which is more
inspired by the video games than the
books as well as one of the two witch's
swords The Witcher series will be
released at the end of the year probably
in December on Netflix
Chris Hemsworth will soon returns with
the camera for his fourth solo
performance as Thor shortly before the
Comicon Thor 4 was announced to the
surprise of many Marvel fans as one of
the films of the upcoming phase 4 of the
MCU
this makes Thor the only MCU superhero
to appear in four of his own solo films
fans of the predecessor Thor 3 will be
happy again because director Taika
Waititi will take over the direction in
Thor 4 again u2 overlaps the live-action
version of Akira will be put on ice for
the time being still possible is an
appearance of Thor in the upcoming
guardians of the galaxy 3 all of you who
have seen Avengers and Game will know
why a release date for Thor 4 as well as
a shooting star Ted is not decided yet
for some time now rumors have been
growing of who will be successor of
Daniel Craig and the James Bond series
this isn't really surprising since part
of the plot in the new Bond 25 will
revolve around the retired James Bond
suggesting that it will be over
afterwards for a few days now the
British actress lashonna Lynch has been
regarded as the successor should the
rumours turn out to be true she would
not only be the first female but also
the first dark-skinned Bond actress
rather she will appear in the new Bond
adventure bond 25 or not is
understandably still an unanswered
question
Lynch thus joins the long list of
possible successors to Daniel Craig
including Thor actor Chris Hemsworth
Idris Elba Henry Cavill and even Robb
Stark 125 is expected to be released in
the US on April 8 2020 we announced 'men
of joe taslim as sap zero as the first
actor for the upcoming Mortal Kombat
film script writer Greg Russell now
comments on the way the film was made
and the possible age rating for the
movie via Twitter he announced that
mortal kombat will get an R rating and
that they want to show the brutal ways
of death on the
for the first time so in terms of
brutality they don't want to be inferior
to the video game template in any way
furthermore this is a counter trend to
other cinema adaptions in the past which
turned out to be much more gentle in
order to reach a wider audience in any
case the highest priority should be to
become more successful than the two film
predecessors of 1995 and 1997 as both
flapped and received more than
devastating reviews which was possibly
also due to the lower H rating a our
rating will also be in the interest of
producer James Wan who has had some
success with all rated movies like
conjuring and saw and exact release date
is not yet known but the release in 2021
is considered to be likely the new Lang
King remake takes a different approach
than its predecessor in an interview
with fandango director Jon Favreau who
was also responsible for the design of
the animals for the animated The Jungle
Book announces that the lifelike animals
in the Lion King remake no longer have
human facial expressions since they want
to pursue a completely naturalistic
approach in the interview he explains
that the characters look too much like
human beings if you push their facial
features too far instead they want to
illustrate the emotions of the animals
entirely through body language he
himself calls it one of the greatest
challenges to convey the charm and
humanity of the 1994 original in the
same way you can find out whether the
new part is as good as the original
since the cinema launched on 9th of July
2009 see our reals cast is starting to
come together after the controversial
cast of area by Holly Bailey the evil
witch Ursula by Melissa McCarthy and
Ariel's friend Fabius by Jacob Tremblay
are also in the cast now an actor for
the male lead role of Prince Eric seems
to have been found and he's no less than
the all-time girl crush and x1 Direction
singer Harry Styles Styles didn't have
much to do with acting up to now yet he
did a great supporting role as a British
soldier in Christopher Nolan's Dunkirk
now styles will embody the be left of
Arielle which at least visually is
closer to the original than some other
Disney cast choices an exact start edge
for Ariel the mermaid has not yet been
set but many journalists expect the
release in 2021
the shooting of a quiet place - has been
running for a short time and that's a
bit surprising after all it wasn't even
clear until recently whether there will
be a sequel to the horror movie success
director John Krasinski will be working
behind the camera again however not in
front of the camera in return his wife
Emily Blunt and the child actress no a
tube and Millicent Simmons will be back
according to Sarah Cruz comm the film is
currently being shot at locations in the
state of New York
Krasinski has also published a photo of
the shooting on Twitter what will also
please fans of the first part is that
the plot of the second part will
seamlessly follow up the first one so
that the story continues a quiet place -
is expected to be released on 20th of
March 2020
[Music]